how
how much do astronomers your colleagues
or yourself
how much of your time and focus goes
towards
worrying about giant earth killer
asteroids
very little um there
there is a relatively small community of
astronomers that they focus on on
objects within the solar system and then
out of that community
a a small fraction worries about
near-earth
asteroids so it's mainly uh an
observational
uh effort to identify individual objects
that may come close to earth because we
can forecast their orbits
using the law of gravity and um
so it's sort of a practical matter to
monitor
uh and figure out which objects might
come close
monitor the sky and you know we can see
objects based on their reflected
sunlight so
the bigger the object is the easier it
is for us to identify it at a greater
distance
and it also depends of course on the
telescope size and
the amount of light that you can collect
within the telescope
diameter now if there was an object that
was similar to the one that took out the
dinosaurs that hit the yucatan
which how soon would we be able to find
it and would is there anything we could
possibly do
oh definitely after its course yeah so
the dinosaurs were
uh went extinct and in fact three
quarters of the earth's
life forms were killed in that um
in that event i mean there was this
giant
rock that they collided with earth it
was roughly the length of uh
manhattan island uh tens of kilometers
and
um and then as it approached the earth
probably it was a beautiful sight but
the fun
of the dinosaurs stopped when the it
collided with earth and caused this
huge environmental damage the the
chick-fil-a crater and sort of a change
in the in the climate of the earth
because of all the dust that was raised
and
um and but perhaps we owe our existence
to that impact because
it changed all together the life forms
that
appeared on the surface of the earth
and then such a big object can be
identified
far enough for us to you know
uh plan years in advance what to do
and there are various ideas about how to
deflect it you can for example
paint a side of it in a color such that
it will reflect or will
will evaporate more quickly um
and then there will be some push on it
and that will deflect it from colliding
with the earth
uh you can detonate something on the
surface of of such an
object and that would also push it aside
you can shine a laser beam uh on one
side of the object and do and achieve
the same goal
there are all kinds of um you can also
shepherd it gravitationally with
with a spacecraft uh all kinds of
suggestions for what to do and
it really depends on the size of the
object and the composition
as to what we want to do you don't want
to for example
uh destroyed into a lot of fragments
because those fragments could hit the
earth with a higher chance
you know during the gulf war there was
this patriot missile
that intercepted um
the the missiles that were sent for
example towards israel and
uh at the early version of these patriot
missiles they just
blasted the incoming missile into pieces
and that caused more damage
than the original missile would of
course so you don't want to do that
uh and we can we will have enough time
to
make appropriate plans depending on
which object is approaching us
we will definitely not get extinct as
the dinosaurs did
the human brain even though it's much
smaller than the body of a dinosaur
it's much more precious uh for long-term
survival
yeah so how did you transition from
studying things like black holes
to studying what you're studying now
like how did you make that transition
well it it was by by chance because um
for example i was studying the first
generation of stars in the universe the
first stars that formed that lit up in
the universe
early on and those stars had an impact
on their environment
they basically broke the hydrogen atoms
around them into their constituent
electrons and protons and
and then if you want to see the scars
left by the first stars on their
environment
you want to image the hydrogen around
them and uh hydrogen emits
faint radio waves and therefore i worked
on a frontier that
talks about you know tries to map the
hydrogen in the early universe
and for that purpose you need to develop
radio observatories observatories are
sensitive at radio frequencies
of around 100 to 200 megahertz and
it so happens that these radio
observatories
operate at exactly the same frequency
band as
fm radio stations and tv stations and
one concern was that there would be
interference from
tv and radio stations on earth but then
it occurred to me that
the same observatories could in
principle eavesdrop
on another civilization you know on a
planet around
another star that transmits those radio
waves and so i wrote a paper about
it that was my first encounter with the
search for technological signatures
then i was i visited abu dhabi
for the inauguration of a new campus for
nyu
and that was uh around 2012 or so
and then uh the tour guide when we
looked at
when we went around the tour guide there
was bragging that
the city lights there are visible from
the moon
uh they're so bright and so that gave me
the idea of
checking how far can you see a city
with the hubble space telescope for
example and
we found with ed turner a collaborator
of mine that
uh in principle the hubble space
telescope can see a city like
tokyo on
pluto you know the edge of the solar
system
of planets um and that was an
interesting idea that
you can look for artificial lights as a
signature of another civilization
and then you can identify these
artificial lights not as reflected
sunlight
by the way the source dims
as it changes its distance from us so
that was my second paper and then the
third one on this subject
was when peop astronomers talked about
uh searching for biological signatures
in the atmospheres of planets and
then it occurred to me that technology
you know if you look for
industrial pollution that would imply
there is an industrial civilization
there
uh and so i wrote a paper about that and
and so gradually it drifted in this
direction that was 2015 and
and then over the past few years
especially because of
uh i published a lot on this subject and
in about the half a year
i will have a book a textbook out of
more than a thousand
pages with my former postdoc
manasvillinga
that lays the foundation for future
studies on this subject of
the search for both primitive and
intelligent life